[Music]
on this Sunday night a border crossing
Wildfire threatens a BC town the
evacuation orders and alerts around
asuyas the whole hill looked like it was
on fire all behind us as BC's Southern
interior becomes the province's Wildfire
hot spot
grocery store staff on strike the
economy cannot sustain itself when the
people who are earning the paychecks
can't afford to live thousands of Metro
workers walk off the job in the latest
in a wave of Labor action across Canada
why Ukraine's president is warning the
war is returning to Russia after a drone
attack closes a Moscow airport and
Canada versus Australia a women's world
cup preview and predictions
global national with faronessor
reporting tonight
good evening and thanks for joining us
first tonight to Canada's erupting
Wildfire emergency hundreds of people in
a BC town have been forced from their
homes after a fast-growing Wildfire
jumped the Canada U.S border
this is looking down towards the Border
Eerie glow seen on the hillside last
night sounding the alarm for locals in a
matter of hours the Eagle Bluff Wildfire
exploded in size the fire front is just
four kilometers from the nearest homes
the entire town of asuyas a popular
holiday hot spot is on edge and under an
evacuation alert despite the Wildfire
deemed out of control it seems to have
slowed but the situation shows just how
quickly everything can change Mike
drolet has our top story tonight
for the moment at least the town of
osoyus BC is breathing a sigh of relief
the town of 400 kilometers east of
Vancouver on the U.S border declared a
state of emergency late Saturday when
over 700 homes were evacuated and
another 2 000 were put on alert it was a
little Restless we
spent the night sleeping in our car or
attempting to sleep in our car but with
the fire right on the edge of town it's
looking like another sleepless night
definitely through like that Peak
burning window later into the afternoon
where we see our highest temperatures
and our lowest relative humidity is
where we're going to watch for that
increase in fire activity U.S satellites
caught the moment the fire started
around 2PM Saturday near Oroville in
Washington state water bombers could be
seen refilling their tanks in the lake
and attacking the Blaze and as late as 6
PM U.S authorities believed it had only
a moderate risk of growth but the fire
now called Eagle Bluff spread quickly
moving North across the border towards
the town of 5000. by 9 pm it was deemed
out of control and the residents of
osoyus were put on notice Joanne Smith
didn't need to be told to leave I could
see the fire coming down the hill from
my back window better to be alive than
to be in your house and
in ashes over at 3 000 hectares are
burning on the U.S side of the Border
nearly 900 in BC small compared to the
blazes in the north of the province BC's
overworked fire Services would like to
keep it that way provided they can
contain its spread microlight Global
News
as the planet's hottest month on record
comes to a closed dangerous temperatures
are still bearing down on parts of the
U.S close to 70 million Americans are
under heat alerts and as Jamie Maraca
explains while there is relief in the
forecast for some a reprieve of the
unrelenting summer scorcher won't come
for everyone
another weekend of excessive heat for
millions of Americans
it's miserable I mean I work outside so
it's just it's even worse heat
advisories are widespread across more
than 10 states from Texas to Florida
Phoenix Arizona has been smashing
records all month and topped 43 degrees
for the 30th day in a row there is hope
Monsoon rains could bring a wave of
relief especially at night a much needed
break from heat so extreme even cacti
have been struggling to survive we talk
about drought and we all make a big deal
of the drought that we're in but it's
more than that it's much warmer this
month's mean Global temperature is
projected to be at least 0.2 degrees
warmer than July of 2019. the former
hottest month in 174 years of
observational data our analysis does
actually show already that July 2023 is
going to be the warmest month on record
not only the warmest July but the
warmest month on the record although
this month is typically the warmest
worldwide experts say human-driven
climate change and a predominant El Nino
year are pushing the Mercury higher
late this week heat and humidity hit the
East Coast too Washington Philadelphia
and New York City hovered around 40
degrees while those regions are
returning to normal Texas Louisiana and
Mississippi are heading into another
Heat Wave even those places are used to
extreme heat have never seen it as hot
as it is now for as long as it's been
Millions starting off the last full
month of Summer hoping for an end to the
dangerous highs Jamie murakart Global
News Houston
in Alberta investigators are looking
into a deadly plane crash in Canada's
country that killed all six people on
board the small aircraft was traveling
from Calgary to Salmon Arm BC on Friday
night when it went down just a few
kilometers north of Kananaskis Village
as Heather urac's West explains poor
visibility may be partly to blame for
the tragedy
at the base of Mount McGillivray in
kananascus Alberta investigators are
trying to determine exactly what went
wrong what caused a Piper pa-32 aircraft
like this one to slam violently into the
Rocky Mountains 30 minutes into its
Journey from Calgary to seminar BC the
aircraft which Departed the Spring Bank
airport at around 9 pm had one pilot and
five passengers on board recovery Crews
assisted by members of Canada's military
and Alberta Parks Mountain Rescue were
able to locate the crash site by homing
a signal coming from an emergency
locator transmitter by early Saturday
morning officials knew nobody on board
the plane had survived we had a bit of
cloud thankfully the crew working with
uh the military where it did an amazing
job being able to spot the recovery and
hone in on the elt and then working with
them closely we were able to get onto
site fairly quickly the body bodies of
the victims and several large pieces of
the aircraft were removed from the
mountain site on Saturday but
investigators say many smaller pieces of
the plane remain officials say based on
the scene it appeared to have been a
violent crash the word violent crash to
me means that that it was at cruising
speed and that it hit the ground or flew
into the ground it could be a very steep
crash site so it could be like a head-on
collision into train the victims all
from the Calgary area had been traveling
to Salmon Arm to attend a church
Gathering their friends and family now
leaning on their faith as they come to
grips with so much devastating loss
Heather York's West Global News
kananascus Alberta
in BC two children who were the subject
of a 10-day long Amber Alert have been
found safe their mother and her
boyfriend are now facing abduction
charges police say the two children were
found last night at a rural property
near Edson Alberta about two hours west
of Edmonton Global News is not
identifying the suspects to protect the
privacy of the children
about 3 700 Metro workers are on the
picket lines for a second day as 27
grocery stores in the greater Toronto
area remain closed employees previously
rejected a tentative contract agreement
reached earlier this month as Amar Khan
explains some staff say the cost of
living is so high they can't even afford
the food they're selling in their own
stores
we want a livable wage Toronto is an
extremely expensive city so many of our
members unfortunately have to use food
banks we have several that live in
community housing
as the Sun beats down on unionized
striking Metro workers the group remains
steadfast with many members already
struggling as the company Nets record
profits some Metro employees say they
can't afford to shop at their own store
and talk about trying to find deals at
cheaper grocery Outlets we have to do
fire hopping see who has what on sale
and instead of going for one grocery
shopping a week we're going for three or
four because we have to go to multiple
locations you want to pick up some
groceries at your own grocery store but
with the skyrocketed prices you can't
even afford to do that vitac has been
working at Metro for five years but to
make ends meet she works a second job
there is no social life I just go to
work and I come home and I try to race
to my other job
okay
residents in Liberty Village who are
being affected by the strike say they're
backing workers rights they got to do
what they got to do so I'm totally okay
with that and I can just rearrange my
day before the strike the bargaining
committee voted it to accept a deal for
Metro but members voted it down when
Metro officials were asked if the
contract included a living wage they
said yes I believe it did the Union
though says that's not true according to
a recent report from the Canadian Center
for policy Alternatives the average
one-bedroom Toronto wage to live is over
33 dollars an hour and according to the
union of full-time workers at Metro
average just over 22 dollars an hour
while part-time employees which make up
the majority of Metro workers make just
a shade over the 1575 minimum wage as
for the fight the union says they're in
it for the long haul this is a fight
that we're going to take and we're going
to help grocery workers everywhere in
Canada this labor dispute is more
widespread than just one grocery chain
contract negotiations are coming up for
Loblaw's owned Dominion in Newfoundland
as well as No Frills in Ontario sobi's
workers will also be negotiating while
Metro's other owned and operated Ontario
stores Food Basics will be at the
negotiation tables in November Amar Khan
Global News Toronto the Ukraine reports
bringing the war deep into Russia coming
up the response after an overnight drone
attack on Moscow
foreign
a powerful bomb has ripped through a
political rally in Pakistan killing at
least 44 people supporters of a
hard-line conservative party were
demonstrating in the country's Northwest
near the border with Afghanistan there's
no immediate claim of responsibility for
the attack
in Ukraine today the country's President
Vladimir zielinski says the war is
returning to Russia overnight the
Kremlin says it intercepted three more
Ukrainian drones over the Skies of
Moscow meanwhile Russian leader Vladimir
Putin claims he never rejected peace
talks to end the invasion of Ukraine an
invasion he started almost a year and a
half ago Redmond Shannon reports
yeah
gin and moscow's Financial District the
Kremlin blames Ukrainian drones as usual
Ukraine is not explicitly taking
responsibility for attacks inside Russia
Alaska but after visiting injured troops
Sunday President Vladimir zielinski
hinted at it
he said that war is gradually returning
to the territory of Russia calling it an
inevitable natural and absolutely Fair
process
the apparent attack on Moscow came on
the symbolic Navy day in Russia Vladimir
Putin at Navy headquarters in Saint
Petersburg
the Russian leader announcing 30 new
ships for the fleet he was joined by
some of the African leaders who were in
Russia for a summit with Putin
this weekend he said Russia remains open
to peace plans put forward by African
countries and China but says Russia
can't step back while it's attacked by
Ukraine attacked in a war that Russia
started he does this all the time he
puts the onus of Peace on others in this
case Ukraine the terms of such talks are
far from anything zelenski is prepared
to consider ukrainians in this moment
cannot accept anything less than getting
back to their borders of 1991. the
prospect for Annie ceasefire also seems
unlikely in the light of Russia raising
the maximum conscription age from 27 to
30 and Putin's assertion that the end of
the Black Sea grain deal will
economically benefit Russia
chaos and bloodshed inside Ukraine
continues with deadly shelling in the
northeastern city of Sumi
and in Kiev another sign of the widening
Chasm between the warring Nations
workers removing Soviet symbols from one
of Europe's tallest statues the 100
meter high motherland Monument Redmond
Shannon Global News London
political unrest ahead the tension and
turmoil in Niger after a military-backed
coup
[Applause]
the French Embassy in Niger attacked by
protesters as thousands marched through
the capital of the former French Colony
all of them in support of the
military-backed coup that ousted the
West African country's president last
week president Muhammad bazoom was
detained by his own presidential guard
accusing him of poor governance and
deteriorating National Security he's
considered a key Ally of the West in
Africa a military Junta led by General
Abdul Rahman Tiani has now taken over
the country
the EU already announced its cut off
financial support to Niger while several
West African nations have also suspended
ties with it as International allies
demand for the immediate reinstatement
of President bazoom as Crystal gomancing
Reports the Takeover has raised more
worries for a region that's fallen into
deeper instability over the last few
years
for stability and prosperity are
disappearing in Niger a landlocked
nation in a region where extremist
groups such as Boko Haram the al-Qaeda
affiliate known as jnim and the Islamic
State of Greater Sahara operate there is
a lot of Hope and
um kind of assumptions that Niger would
be remain this bulwark of stability in
the region
Niger is one of the poorest nations in
the world it's also where Millions have
fled to escape conflicts Elsewhere on
the continent after the military took
the president hostage a national
broadcast took place Friday announcing
the Constitution had been suspended
identified as the new leader the head of
the presidential guard cited the
country's deteriorating security
situation as well as poor economic and
social governance for the coup
there have been seven coups in West and
central Africa since 2020. Molly and
Burkina Faso were the latest in fact
there were two in Burkina Faso just last
year the russian-based Wagner group is
active in both countries at the recent
Russia African Summit the leaders from
both countries attended and praised
Russian leadership and support
our African heads of state must stop
acting like puppets who dance every time
the imperialists pull the strings said
the South proclaimed head of Burkina
faso's interim government Niger is a
western Ally in combating Islamic
extremism in the region and many
countries use it as a base in support of
counter-terrorism efforts more than one
thousand French troops are positioned
there the U.S Italy and the European
Union Block also have a presence in the
country as does Canada under operation
nibirius a training Mission aimed at
bolstering local military and security
forces in a statement to Global News
after the president was deposed the
Department of National Defense said
there is a limited number of CAF members
present in support of planning and
liaison for future training serials
there are no plans to evacuate at this
time we are monitoring the situation
closely with Nigeria collapsing we're
looking at an entire belt across the
African continent of countries that are
experiencing tumultuous instability at
the moment the Russian president offered
security support to all African leaders
who attended his two-day Summit possibly
increasing Wagner's reach and stoking
tensions with the West
Crystal gemancing Global News London
[Music]
next a look ahead at Canada's crucial
match against Australia in the Women's
World Cup
[Music]
the clock is ticking down to Canada's
biggest game so far at the Women's World
Cup they'll face the co-host Australians
on Monday in what is essentially a Do or
Die match joining us now from Sydney is
Adam peacock host of Seven Sports Adam
thanks so much for being here
no problems so I'm sure you and I are
both rooting for opposing teams in this
game but can you set up what's at stake
here for Australia and Canada
uh everything pretty much is sort of uh
heightened what it all means but it
pretty much has reached the peak of what
you aim for in football and that's at a
World Cup and then performing and
getting to The Knockout stages and from
an Australian perspective it hasn't gone
all that well so far we've had a loss
the other night to Nigeria which is a
huge surprise and we've been without our
best player in San Kerr who's declared
her availability for this match but we
need her the way we're playing at the
moment before this tournament some
groups had labeled Group B the so-called
group of death can you remind us what
that means and were those predictions
right
there's always a group of Death at a
World Cup and like people just love
giving that uh giving that label to one
group which looks tougher than all of
the others look this this is a very
difficult group you've got the hosts
Australia who are in great form going in
you've got Canada of course you guys
know that they won the Olympic gold in
Tokyo Nigeria 11 time African Champions
rank 40 in the world but much better
than that because they don't play
against Top Class opposition all that
often an island a European team who are
very hard to break down so it was a
difficult group sometimes these groups
at a World Cup you get one game which
stands out and you go okay we can we can
definitely say we're going to get
through that one but not Group B is
vodka you mentioned from an Australian
perspective it sounds like things
haven't been going as well just
generally what's your assessment of how
the tournament is going so far the games
are quite spread out with venues across
two countries multiple cities does it
feel like fans are getting into it
oh definitely yeah it surprised a lot of
people here like in Australia um there's
a lot of sporting content for people to
Feast their eyes on we've got our footy
codes as we call them like AFL and rugby
league I might go into it it'll just
confuse it all your viewers but we've
got those big things going on right now
we've got Cricket happening but this has
captured people's imagination because
it's something different like um a
couple of nights ago in Brisbane we had
50 000 people watching Brazil and France
I was at a game in Sydney not that long
ago 30 000 people watching Colombia and
Korea yeah it's captured people's
imagination definitely all right before
we let you go without playing favorites
which team do you think wins tomorrow
and why
well there's a big difference between
which team I think will win and which
team I hope will win obviously all the
hope is with Australia it's going to be
tied I can honestly see it coming down
to one big moment hopefully it falls
Australia's way but Canada really loved
their second half against Ireland the
way priestman changed the tactics
changed the Personnel so in my opinion
they're actually favorites based on that
going in so I wouldn't be surprised if
Canada win but be very very happy if
Australia did well said all right that
is a seven sport host Adam peacock Adam
thank you very much
no problem
and that is global national for this
Sunday night I'm nitu garcha tonight's
year Canada is Emerald Lake near field
British Columbia we love seeing your
Canada please keep emailing your photos
to viewers at globalnational.com thanks
so much for watching Donna will be back
at the anchor desk tomorrow have a great
night
[Music]